back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
Oh g'day brother take a going man you've
changed now you came back from Australia
just you just walk it around different
you think you really you think you're
better than this man no I don't think
I'm better than anything brother
happy to be a man how you going hey mate
Foster's huh
do you drink Foster's out there I
smelled it on a lot of people's breath
Foster's is actually an American thing
is it really yeah oh Jesus Christ
crikey yeah we had a good time man I saw
JA not giraffe what is it
kangaroo you saw a kangaroo yeah did you
get close with one it's like a giraffe
that wasn't like a really bad accident I
feel like um oh yeah I got close you can
go in the park and pet him there ya are
they're basically the el Caminos are the
animal kingdom and where aren't they
yeah cuz they got real short arms like
they can't even you know they can't even
touch their two hands together the kids
if they had like a little if one a man
like a little WOM they're basically
t-rex but with fur like say if it was
gonna roll some dice right and in one it
something you want to roll dice you want
to switch to your other hand you look at
your hand they can't do that you gotta
pop it like yeah having grapes you know
toss two nuts in it's about like a
little person with a broken or I'm
having grapes mandatory Oh travesty bro
whose kangaroos are on nyquil and
something they're on Downer's bro cuz
they're not excited when you're there
are they I've been there man they're
like touch the kangaroo I was like
what's wrong with them yeah it's tired
it was a unique group I'll say that man
they had one arm they had a couple of
mixed boys out there ones that I think
maybe had like a one black parent or
whatever then they were [ __ ] whiling
were they yeah you know one over there
having like a uh not a cigarette but
like a little blonde or something you
know little blunt down under yeah I can
get lit up down under
you know listen to some Trick Daddy and
stuff like that it's yeah well trick
daddy baby cuz but yeah man everybody
said hello bro a lot of people asked
about you
they're like what the [ __ ] is up with
that guy bring ding Brendan yeah
do you like tell burning a good [ __ ]
safe oh very cool Thank You Man yes I
told that guy said no I'm not gonna tell
now but then I just forgot it you just
did it that's all good dude
yeah jet-lagged I was thinking I was in
Cleveland somehow I got jet lag you know
watch gently on the airplane double
check we on the jet lag
oh yeah it's bad bro it's really I start
talking and chinesey dude in the middle
of the night I can't even help it that's
how it goes dude let's get you a koala
yeah I seen a koala held a koala can we
cut to that pic of me holding a koala
it's on you don't want and actually they
really look like chin a little bit
koalas do look like chin I've actually
seen chin with a koala and it's
basically a family reunion oh yeah
everybody asked about you about Chan too
because Jeff went when you win yeah
actually went to yes trip ever
yeah really best rumored there and uh
violent Australian Darwin the best
people Dublin was dub yeah Wow we had a
good time
chin and that koala a way to door
friendly with each other I could see
that dude if I were a koala dude and I
saw you I'd be like oh my god well I was
going Papa I went wow they speak English
chlamydia
but chlamydia you do what is it you know
it's just a [ __ ] a pill get rid of it
yeah it's chilled you get it on Saturday
and you finished with it by Wednesday
you know if you don't have an Australian
you ain't doing it right that's why I
hope you got it Oh bro I'll say this man
but everybody was asking about you and
then a couple times on stage you know I
brought up the idea of maybe doing like
a live King in the sting form and they
were damn nuts so yes one got killed his
friend right there you so excited guy
just unleashed an alligator on his
friend yeah but some guy said gang
hanging some other dude said buzz
and hit his friend with a sword he's
like both Bulls Bravo's dude 1 and I was
in Cleveland doing shows and at the mean
great a girl came up didn't got in my
face nose the nose and like be nice to
steal man yeah nice to do it what she
goes you need to back off of him I went
thank you girl
he's gonna roast me on the show like I'm
just trying to be cool man
and she's like be nice if he needs the
help I'm like you need help as he was
doing it Estrella
but 42nd Dave Chappelle out there chill
lady she was cool though then she wiped
by McGee me smile went buzz bah ha ha ha
all right all right mental health issues
at all have a good day have a good day
lady a lot of undercover buzz buzzers
over there in Cleveland yeah there you
are dress it you look like a [ __ ]
black or Drake dude that's the crazy
thing is you look black or drunk how
close is great to get in his ass beaten
by draymond Green
my godson closes by stealing draymond
Green ladies trash dude I'm rocking this
today my boy sent it to me and he also
sent you a dent left lift shrimp oh yeah
you gave it to me how do you walk in
authentic authentic son you know what's
funny when you walked up with that
Jersey it was like in a bag and it was
like green and yellow I thought you got
me a Subway sandwich I was like what a
pieces oh yeah
cuz you came back from Australia just a
footlong sub real friends don't get
friends footlong dude that picture with
the Koala looks like you were a Vietnam
vet with PTSD oh well if you looked so
scared
well first of all me and the Koala have
a very similar nose if you notice that
yeah you guys are very similar you look
hey shorty wanna Doug right there dude
you you a motto why you so tan bottles
in the club that's a lot of koalas all
up in your titty like so damn probably
not it a little on my shirt man that
thing live man your problem and your
face looking like that dude you're so
while a sexy bro bottles in the class
let's see that same nose bro
very similar now foster-care knows all
what are you talking about dude I'm a
very small nose in a lot of black
communities not know Kimmy I grew up and
dude you look so like just like worn out
man and you're so tan you look like
you've been working out [ __ ] glory
hole outdoors in the street yeah look
like a guy that makes really strong
smoothies for Drake bro didn't get
molested by Michael Jackson and grew up
you're sad about it
you guys unmolested that's my
documentary
I'm molested not up in here starring
Theo von the chosen one bro you're such
a bandwagon where you drive the
bandwagon dude you're like all the ball
I don't like what is it this week oh oh
I bet you have a st. Louis Blues tattoo
on your chest
well you're a [ __ ] salesman bro and
you're selling out what's in your
briefcase out bro you're [ __ ] selling
out actually I'm going for Golden State
I just lost this because of my friend
send it to me and my special is
available in Canada sure you look like a
[ __ ] ham hock from Croatia dude you
like Kevin Spacey's lapdog bro I know
Kevin it's hazy - that's a nice guy man
yes guy very talented as well yeah used
to be VP just hit me up Dustin Poirier
man he's training right now I just got a
noun firm bro take your ass - bye I'm
thinking about it yeah I'm off that
weekend I'm gonna get o Europe right
after Isis would you go see what would
you go absolutely not
you wouldn't know why for free yeah if
we were doing shows I don't travel for
free brother right no you taking away
from that though to see the [ __ ]
night Jimmy dope nah
flying 37 hours to do by sitting front
row to watch that fight be at my house
just click watching Dustin do work I
used on the show while you were gone
yeah I saw the pepper put the pitcher
miss was it cool yeah he's the best man
yeah you got me choked up did he yeah he
got me choked up on there talking about
his girl being with him from day one
yeah it's like damn you got a ride or
die man yeah dude he saw he's a unique
guy man and he's actually not funny like
you you got to get to know his
personality BX as a goofy side too you
know
no he's funny for sure he's an
interesting dude bro I asked him one
time I was like so you know what about
school he like what school like eighth
grade they said you and him went the
same school I just thought they stopped
in Louisiana like there's only
Elementary and then after that all now
you got this Louisiana
bro whatever dude you're built like that
last piece of bread bro that [ __ ]
dumb up the bun in a lot of gay circles
you're known as that last piece of
[Laughter]
because you and Dustin finished 5th
grade yeah take your anger out on me
yeah not my fault your mom [ __ ] up you
correctly there's 12 grades you idiot
okay not fair yeah bro bet the under
dude if you like schools
but I remember tenth grade Louisiana was
recipes that was our main class and to
graduate you'd learn magic oh dude I'm
thinking about going to the fight though
we'll see man are you really yeah dude
stay home but go to Europe oh you're on
tour in Europe I'm heading to Europe
that following week so you know bounce
so you go before then bounce yeah I'm
just I'm nervous about being in that
audience like if people would like
attack us now here's the thing Dustin
brought up the the same point he's like
you know if I if I win I got to get out
of it it's not like that that place is
so modern Americanized so much money
there's none of that [ __ ] going on there
you really didn't have anything to worry
about have you heard of the Middle East
yeah I have
good places man not don't Isis scare you
away look how would they use among to
you Hooters okay
do you love Hooters in [ __ ] the
middle-east broke with Hooters student
in some countries Hooters is like they
it's the American Embassy
yeah it's called New Orleans you you and
doesn't have nothing to worry about I
don't know man it's such a tough fight
for him though brother oh yeah I'm rude
i'm never rude so hard for anyone in my
life after you're done I give him huh
guys I love you man
and they walk around that is such a
tough fight yeah it's a fight if Daniel
Cormier was fighting him I'd be worried
for DC yeah that's up good Kabhi vez but
you know what you gotta fight it that's
the thing it's like if you don't do the
fight you don't know you you don't you
don't know you got to do the fight what
is the other option not doing the fight
now that's his job right that's the
thing if you milk driver you got a drive
I drop that [ __ ] nectar of the cow
drop that white nectar off but the thing
is with Dustin if you're gonna fight
khabib do we have to do it in Dubai can
we not do it out here I would have
island chips against him I would agree
but they've been stacked against him his
whole life man I wouldn't do it in a
neutral ground I feel like like maybe
Haiti or something too in England yeah
do it in [ __ ] England yeah I like
England dude I asked us on my - do you
have any control and he's like nah
they're gonna tell me and I just gotta
go I said but then when you beat on then
you demand to fight in New Orleans oh
yeah I would demand a fight I feel great
teacher my yard but demand a fight your
front yard I got in Miami
dude I'd fightin but back in my mother's
womb bro on Turk you feel me nobody's
beating you there dude did you say
hopefully not nobody's beating you no
one is it's gonna be that Dagestan Ian
nightmare
oh yeah but I don't know man raw you
seen him fight before huh yeah watch
some of his face duties as legs too much
I think you know more clutch or do you
think you just want more meat more boxes
I'm just warmin it's like you look it's
boxing dude if it were I think he
probably undeniably pound for pound the
best twister player in the entire
[ __ ] world will compete yeah
pretty good the guy has legs bro he's
like a
you know he's like a tarantula man he's
like 70 legs Russian tarantula I don't
think they exist do not would be
surprised if at night his legs [ __ ] each
other make another good leg
they don't say that x yes but his legs
are like arms dude yeah it's like he's
got nine arms dude I feel like I haven't
seen you in two years
really yeah thinking about me that much
man well sorry I miss you
well everybody was asking about you and
the tall Viet mr. chin over there
Wow chin took Australia by storm yeah
awesome
still you could still see a shadow in
some places I'll never forget chin would
dinner because I came out with no
openers nothing I just go see ders when
I was first go out cold that's my sex
move cold wet and chin would introduce
me I'll never forgive this junk Oh
all right everybody this housing but a
funeral a very passive funeral or a
phone call - and ever the murder
victim's family so this is what anyway
all right everybody put your hands
together you know from the big brown
breakdown and firing the kid he's my
boss Brendan Schaub my boss and I came I
woke to my do you got it you gotta stop
with my boss stuff that's not that ain't
good - yeah it's a sex tournament a lot
of those foreign countries my boss and
he runs a tight ship and hope he treats
you guys betting does me you ready -
laughs here he is yeah get ready to fill
out a w-9 like I did but I'm not the guy
you ready to work overtime and I get
paid for it so I feel like I work at
Apple he's my boss and has brendan job
yeah
Chin's a freaking legend I'm a mystery
dude take it on the chin ko Bebe's gonna
bro let's [ __ ] get into this episode
man it's good to be back to be back in
[ __ ] touch me bro you got chlamydia
dude I may have it actually I will say
this man I went straight from with a
koala didn't shower went to the plane
and I my eyes were swollen the whole way
home eyes are little itchy and there I
felt this I think I'm allergic to koalas
and especially those noses any of the
similar noses I'm having an allergic
reaction
I could imagine that dude I could
imagine you Chin's running the keyboards
today shout-out to a Nick and Derek yeah
and that is very passive-aggressive it's
in jail right now for we don't know but
involves small children when Derek is on
the road with Pauly Shore so he can't be
here
first of all Nick was a premature baby
so he's way out kick discovers you he's
born three weeks for you supposed to be
every day's goals for him imagine every
day is hash tag goals yeah can you
imagine that dude you know nice together
he's my boss what do you got you know we
come to the main stage it's my bowl
there you go first Alan Garcia is Oliver
Santana what are we doing right now
King under sting at the L was good
restart at chin restart even ready bro
women thank you no you're not prepared
today chin unbelievable dude here you go
nice lighter from Massachusetts so
there's this song that everyone is
debating about the same it's not country
or it is country and I just want to know
your opinion on it what's your opinion
on that little nods old-time road song
King I just think it you know that song
yeah dude can someone hit it for me can
I just get canceled and just play a
little bit for me just [ __ ] dude a
black dude taking over country I'm not
gonna do you see the [ __ ] in Australia
there are you Dan six-year-old woman in
Florida
[Music]
damn he made a movie it's a long one
all right ready go get that fiddle hear
that fiddle this is why I doing the club
like this bro
oh my god are you a stripper no I'm what
happen you got something stuck in your
pants nah the rodeo bro Billy Ray Cyrus
up in this joint bro you look like Billy
Ray Cyrus he made every wrong choice in
life
[Music]
damn it's okay man I don't think it's a
that is the jam of 2019 and you got
Billy Ray Cyrus on there a man who made
make Miley Cyrus yeah me and bro yeah it
first of all did you hit that hits you
you couldn't help but your dicks are
popping bro even though you're tired and
you're from Australia you're jet-lagged
like a [ __ ] you dick start
popping you're gonna blow a [ __ ]
you're gonna blow up l7 s9 bro what I'm
saying is anybody could conceive Miley
Cyrus dude all you need is a [ __ ]
bong and in a long afternoon I feel like
and a skill crane she looks like
something that you know was conceived
with a nice ovary and a skill crane how
do you that's a songbird of our
generation [ __ ] dude what did she
[ __ ] herself on the top of a
Volkswagen like two years ago eating
weed or something no nothing be
realistic okay talking about her songs
wrecking ball yeah the jam of 2007 -
okay which I admit was a good song if
you were home by yourself at night yeah
all right she married Thor's little
brother did she yeah killing it yeah but
that guy was one of the Winklevoss twins
wasn't he a lot of those guys seem like
[ __ ] you you both you and your brother
[ __ ] handsome get the [ __ ] out of
here dude I'm saying that doesn't him
well one of them's gonna get hit by a
truck or walk into one of those blades
like a an airport like that model
accidentally did dude here's the thing
we got a king this country song because
at first the light a country song that's
what the man was - no it is because the
white people denied it and then he went
I coul hold my beer and then he went and
got Billy Ray Cyrus and then he got the
stamp of approval and that's the number
one song in America they didn't want
country song yeah number one country
song it is yes like the number one -
right it's number about deadly number
one song country took it off their list
really like this ain't country all right
and then Billy Ray Cyrus like I'll help
you out yeah now it's number one I don't
think their country took it all cuz they
were racist I think they just think is
this country music you know to me
like a mix it's like a country kind of
rap that's what it is a little bit more
but I think it's a great song man I
think it's catchy I don't think I would
argue of whether or not it's a country I
don't think it who cares about that [ __ ]
it's the number one song it's like you
don't even need the country chart it's
so John to a matter
yeah it is it matter anymore a lot of
things emerged but then I thought of
Shania Twain she had that kick turn
stomp stomp
remember that something like a woman oh
yeah that was a little bit wild you know
but this one I mean I don't know you
they talk about [ __ ] in it who knows
man it's a banger man that's the it's a
writer no doubt I feel like I'm in
Django just [ __ ] oh yeah oh you
definitely seem you know Unchained bro
yeah and I think yeah it's amazing man
I'm going to I can't write in the back
horse sees the word horse a lot a lot of
horses riding on a horse he hat is matte
black or just black um tractor lean all
in my bladder that's pretty good that
could have been the line that turned
them off too you know a lot of countries
don't have lean in them so maybe they're
like well is this country you know also
you can whip your Porsche not a lot of
country songs have Porsches in them yeah
I cheated on my baby now they're you're
back in the country my life is a mover
and laron my booty pool riding and
boobies cowboy house of Gucci Wrangler
on my booty yeah dude this is poetry
I always beautiful man it's science oh
it's definitely dude it's a lovely King
it definitely King it is it country I
mean I don't think it matters it's the
number one song it's it's it's
everything I think it's a head
dang it man nice this one's from Angela
Ellis what's up shorty Brendan just
wondering what's taking you so long to
get your ass to upstate I was there
before do a girl nobody remembers I know
but let's face it some kids really just
aren't great I'm just wondering where
you guys stand on it so keep doing what
you're doing Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
that's why people are so soft you don't
get a trophy for participating you got
to stand out you beat the rest of the
people you get away my son in a race the
other day he didn't get his cookie
you got a win you got a win yeah I think
you got a look if there's no adversity
then there's no but there's no there's
no journey I feel like you know like
what's the journey of everybody's okay
and then the truth is everybody gets the
trophy - your good trophy but then
really little [ __ ] Stanley's the one
hitting the dingers so he's the one
getting all the accolades he's the one
getting you know somebody showing him
the tits in a van or whatever after the
game he's getting all the goodies extra
orange slices maybe trying to climb in a
van thinking you're gonna get some tits
and you like nah man you [ __ ] you
suck dude these peewee lizard up for you
bro you gotta hit them homers yeah dude
you gotta have somebody to be you know
that's how that kid learns hey I'm a
statistician you know exactly if we're
all getting trophies like damn maybe I
can go then being naw man
dude Darrell over there's going to the
NBA yeah Darrell's going to the NBA
you're not you know we all get the same
trophy dear I'll should probably stay
playing basketball you should get in the
books yeah no I'm saying Donald should
get a contractor's license
it's different I agree dude that's how I
learned look and when it comes to
baseball I'm best in the concession
stand there's a deep left one time base
down okay
oh I was valet Brazos Valley Park girls
are great yeah put all the shitty kids
no one can hit it that far deep left
like we had a left fielder and then I
was in deep left dude like out by the
cars like I'm her at one point just
getting in somebody's van resting I'm
reading some [ __ ] mushrooms out there
we're in an away game and [ __ ] losing
my game through the water cause I was
playing the 30th inning back in the
woods just [ __ ] trying to reorganize
my toes dude I was [ __ ] up on some
boomers daddy daddy number double zero
so I look I agree with you participation
trophies eat a dick man they got too
many soft young bucks rolling out there
you know you got a guy rolling and
trying to get into Northern Illinois
State University and he's rolling up
there without you know I did you know I
was seventh honorable mention out there
you know in Stanley's plumbing golden
Vikings another steam all [ __ ] yeah get
out of here get out of here for everyone
man that's why some people are [ __ ]
yeah if everybody's a trophy then
there's no point in having a trophy yeah
I feeling that but you didn't earn it
what are we doing man yeah I don't think
they should give all the kids orange
slices at halftime not a bad game my
dad's like nah you ain't getting water
you don't get to your home slice do you
know my dad when I was a kid whose mom
made him orange slices dude yeah or the
kid who scored touchdowns he needed the
electrolytes sugar not me yeah the rest
of us had scoliosis and scurvy out the
Wang brah
you know yeah brother buddy yeah my
buddy could uh he could like do cool
tricks on his back bone with a marble
you know he'd never had any enough
vitamin C did he get a trophy no he
didn't get a trophy dude good decent
dancer though I'll say that all right
now you know what he got was a health
problem oh dude yeah he's got way I mean
only certain type of shirts will really
fit him unique shirts
yeah probably good let's get into an
angel I think you're on to something
upstate New York
yes ding it's shiny trophies as a kid
yeah a lot for what
RC car racing arson car or spurning cars
Wow unbelievable dude unbelievable if
one of the old used to race
remote-control cars yeah that's right
yeah built them racing you built them
yourself first place all the time
you race easy this place call rch did
you ever think about jumping in a real
car so you could get a perfection out of
it my Honda Civic remember yeah
change oh they knew you had a Honda
Civic without ever even knowing you
every Asian person ever met is that a
Honda Civic yeah it's fixed up and
everything no of course it is dude I can
see the [ __ ] fan on the back but did
you think about racing that thing I did
raise it he's a race it's very very slow
but we did race just in a straight line
you weren't on a tracked tracks and
streets
damn you deeded tracks yeah do you want
awards second place diesel they call him
diesel fast and fierce 19 over here all
right various definitely dude furious
serious Nick [ __ ] stood him up and
made him work at the last minute so good
luck surviving tomorrow Nick yeah
and he's getting he's gonna get that
quick super quick now but you'll hear
come a mile away
giant Finn like a whale alright what
else I was super spoiler alright next
was your favorite yeah I know you did
j-rod oh boy yeah
[Music]
is he on salary too
well he's definitely some list to eat
where's that panty on this here over
here the therapist I like that guy
though I like j-rod do dig picks tricky
tricky game also you gotta get the right
angle and the lighting even a small dick
if you got that big dick energy it's
easy take it from anywhere you have the
small dick energy it's all about the
angles bro the light and grease it up
get creative yeah maybe put some put
draw some eyes on it you know I'm saying
put a little fur coat on it or sometime
used to do this trick you get like if
you caught a small fish you put it in
the back of like a little remote-control
truck and you take a pitch I'm like oh I
caught this big fish oh that's dope so
that's what I could do get a micro
machine yeah make your dick look like
anime you dick over the top of it put
some rope on it yeah that's a great idea
dude like dang gotta get creative man
yeah call some eyes on it I like what I
like to do from time to time is I like
to take the wrapper from a Cadbury egg
just put over the tip of your dick oh
yeah yeah yeah do that old like it's
like war war one do that old hochiminh
kind of attack sort of thing when they
had the those special hats are you
talking about d-day there's also great I
am I think so dude well there's also
like the Trojan horse move you know I'm
saying oh yeah yeah but you want to hype
it up cuz then when what is that one is
that the one where you hide in
somebody's yard the Pearl bunch of
seamen through their window you could or
you just kind of put it over the sheets
and you just you know you get the good
angle and it's just like open the sheets
so it looks like it's a Trojan horse but
really it's just about all taking that
yeah you'll be all right dude damn Jim
brought up Trojan horse of even loaded
on that left shrimp Jersey look at this
pizza had by side
[ __ ] cartoon take a picture let's see
who that guy is modeling the plug yeah
cuz his goal is to become a serious
actor this the only gig this man got you
got a [ __ ] you see you could buy a
small one of those and put around your
dick though oh yeah if you had a fun hat
on your dick dude ranch hat
hey your dick black make it look like a
moray eel put it in a tank put put put
it put it well with some [ __ ] Bubble
Guppies and my wiener kind of looks like
a fat asian guy with other one of those
hats on can you google fat guy with that
asian yeah uh you dick looks like Chef
Boyardee Chef Boyardee Dom chef boy a
cockatiel yeah my dick looks just like
that dude I say Korean too oh he is
Korean of course he is it a very Korean
kind of dick area you know looks soft
though you know like nice oh yeah yeah
no idea dude here's the thing with Dave
Taylor's is my dad here's the thing with
dick pics make sure when you do blasted
out it's a good one cuz if it does leak
you wanted to be like oh my god I can't
believe they posted that yeah you don't
want a bad dick picking out there make
sure if you're gonna send it
that thing's flawless yeah that's the
only advice I got for you yeah and I've
also you know I know a guy named Jason
Tebow he's a comedian and he are neat
guy you know the words like different
shirts and stuff every time I see him
and he um he let me use his dick for a
couple years deep pegs and I paid him
like $40 for two dick pics and I would
use those were they good rented yeah
that's not bad business rented dick so
everyone's like oh my god they were good
man he [ __ ] had a cigarette burn on
the edge of it that wasn't my style but
that's him right there that's my boy he
had that very kind of like he had that
Renaissance Fair looking kind of dead he
had the battle dick like he was the
front center like a dick he liked it he
just eaten a big turkey leg and maybe
wanna you know wanted a little jousting
though right well good on but it was
also maybe gonna paint this half
total Ren Faire type of wean rent the
dick bro I say if you're gonna send them
they better be good but in general price
yeah I'm gonna sting the axe man I think
yeah take care yeah show you dick in
person do do the old fashioned run up
show you a dick real fast and run off
yeah we caught flashing yeah see so how
can this is a lot here let me see
something oh there we go
nothing's so loud time to pay the bills
let me tell you honestly that sometimes
they say procrastination is a bad thing
but I'm here to tell you who knows if it
is because life isn't always so black
and white sometimes procrastination can
work in your favor I was late to a
building that ended up burning down
thank God
yeah for example if you need life
insurance but you've been putting it off
congratulations
yeah but doesn't it take forever filled
doesn't take like seven years to figure
all this stuff out no not now technology
you procrastinated long enough that
technology has made it easy for you to
get life insurance I just got my policy
I've been thinking about it ruminating
on it procrastinating not
procrastinating but also procrastinating
also living policy genius well they
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape is there any pressure or how about
hidden fees bro no you're talking a
policy genius brother once you apply
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape no sales
pressure no hidden fees oh what's that
hiding behind that Bush over there of
feet wrong just financial protection and
peace of mind but let me ask you this
you go to heaven you're covered thank
God you know what though I know they
handle life insurance but can they help
me with I don't know a home insurance
auto insurance disability insurance oh
yeah if you get hit by lightning if
you're in your car if you're in your
house whatever policy genius got you so
if you need life insurance but you've
been busy doing literally anything else
or nothing check out policy genius
it's the easy way to compare all the top
insurers find the best value put that
lay that money down on your own life
policy genius.com nobody wants to shop
for life insurance nobody wants to be
milling around thinking oh maybe I'm
gonna be dead ain't nobody got time for
them but thankfully policy genius made
it easy
get in there get it done policy genius
calm time to buy few more pants dude if
you're like me you're not always paying
attention your bank account I'm just
like what is happening I have no idea
and then the moment you see that you've
overdrawn it's too late man so you end
up spending 37 dollars on a single cup
of coffee thanks bank fees yeah no more
introducing the Dave app that's right
Dave got your back dave has your back
Dave huh is the number one budgeting app
in America because he saves you from
overdraft fees and Brendan will be like
that he'll be sue to be throwing making
it rain and they're like uh you're at
the butcher shop yeah I go Dave Dave
Dave okay so guess what Dave tells you
about upcoming bills and can advance you
$75 from your next paycheck with no
credit check and no interest dang dang
that's all 75 go wild kids get the Dave
app for just $1 per month that's 12
dollars a year which is way less than an
overdraft fee and you never have to pay
one ever again that's right Dave got
your back and Dave got your front Dave
we hope you budget for upcoming expenses
could be anything you got a flat tire
your girls you know maybe she's uh you
know with child whatever you need some
milk or whatever Dave will take care of
it man if you're spending too much and
if you need cash fast advance you
seventy-five dollars in just 90 seconds
and Dave Mark Cuban is an investor in
Dave because he believes in it that's
right mark the Cuban 3 million people
already used Dave to save up to one
thousand dollars a year in overdraft
fees that's why it's the number one
budging app in the App Store it that
soft 75
Dave dot-com / K 80s
it really helps it's immediate savings
go now - Dave calm / Katz k 80s spelled
just like it sounds
my boy da ve Dave calm / Katz K 80s yeah
bet on yourself put down that dollar a
month get that hitter
take care of your budget just me make it
rain with 75 oh we're at the butcher
shop support the podcast alright moving
on to rip my drip first one is brave and
mick nut from atlanta georgia bro vans
McNutt dude i'm guessing it's the dude
bro vans making that definite as real
name but no Jewish and Irish you think
he looks like Armenian and Italian in
that suit good call bro vans McNutt make
nut all over that grass
yeah damn brother God dang coochie top
huh looks very Liberace ish and he
dressed his girl looks like in a like
Santa's car seat bro
looks like he ripped the [ __ ] seats
out of an old old most feel sexy bro
maroon thrive
bro that's a sexy look on that little
Dame right there oh yeah you look look
at the pup in the back he looks like I
hate he looks like a race war going on
like if you look at it he looks like
John VAR fade like if John rabe a
different game of Thrones he would wear
that that's what it looks nice yeah I
don't know what's going on there man he
an - lets see his hand Cossack hey check
out the dick Peters on this dude he's
obviously the hand of the king I'm in
the third season now Game of Thrones
round 3 yeah good luck you know Loras is
a homosexual two doors that guy's gonna
apparently well well yeah we got the
white long I know that
so that does boy here a couple of grams
rattling in his [ __ ] a couple of
loose rocks look at the hand on that guy
yeah some fat is the hand of the king
bro let's see that jacket again oh dude
yeah he looks like he looks like the or
he looks like a nice guy let me say that
he looks like he owns every nightclub in
LA that he look he looks like you runs
the front rope at a nightclub he looks
like he at the same pattern they used
for everything at the Cosmopolitan Hotel
in Las Vegas he looks like can give you
the best table at STK steak house yeah
cosmopolitan oh it looks definitely sexy
but also relaxed like Game of Thrones
yeah he looks like the guy that always
stays at Hard Rock Cafe oh yes
24 hours day 24/7 yeah it looks like he
goes out into this car and eat an omelet
in his car they save money and they goes
back inside yeah he looks like he has a
yearly membership to the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame I didn't think you're gonna
make me laugh on this next guy his
name's John O'Connor
he's a batboy for the Tampa Bay Rays and
the picture was taken on opening day
wants to see Brennan wants to send
Brennan one of their Dover Devil Rays
throwback jerseys oh I'd love that dogs
your bar here hell yeah levitator huh
damn bill gates got tall yeah oh it
looks like Manute Bol gates dude how
tall is this dude look like my new ball
and Bill Gates [ __ ] just had a baby
in a lab yeah look like Sean Bradley and
Bill Gates but that's an old-school
reference some of those guys people know
exactly okay just check in dude
yeah he looks uh he looks a little bit
like Elton John is what can you zoom in
on his face a little yeah beautiful
young guy look at him happy - is he
polish being that happy I would assume
so straight teeth I bet he's the best
[ __ ] bat boy in all of America it's
hard to convict - grab those babies a
bad boy yeah
a big open house beautiful area out
there too now I love Tampa eboard
definitely hell yeah he bore City man
had a lot of gay men down there and a
lot of thugs - yeah it's very confusing
a lot of trap houses a lot of strip
clubs I don't know which one I'm going
into both a good both pretty cheap
Akshay
yes some guy rolled up on me and uh and
try to get me to jerk off in my wallet
and then give it to him so I'm like is
this I was like a gay guy or throws yeah
yeah it's a lot going on yeah but yeah
he seems like a nice guy Tampa Bay dude
let's just get that temper I'll rock
that Devil Rays Jersey baby and how is
he able to levitate okay can we just
look at the fact that he is levitating
what kicks are those from here looks
like Reebok uh who gives a [ __ ] what
kicks the are the guy is levitating how
does that not because you can buy shoes
that do that for you so you can't you've
never seen Back to the Future the Maggs
Wow look he's got the ankles of a
freakin young ballerina or like someone
that was like hell raised in a cage and
not let into the Sun those look like
some kicks my yet w-would where are
those socks or is it as natural skin
tone I think it is natural skin tone out
in Tampa that's tough they do - it's
impressive yeah that is so white bro
that is like sheep white good for him
dude shoutout to this dude good luck
with Tampa Bay son let's get that buzz
buzz jersey going go D raise baby gang
gang son buzz it buzz next one's from
Phyllis Felicity Heller from Halifax
Nova Scotia and she says she intron
hide-a-bed she says tell brain how much
I can step your dick up chin ooh
mamacita we got a little London lover
here she's a Nova Scotia yeah you well
she has the British flag that you
learned for on bro that ain't a British
flag dude yeah that's Great Britain dude
and she has the skyline of London god
dammit your mom dude that's your local
jack that is the Uncle Jack that's the
British dude she is tap Nova Scotia Nova
Nova show show bro
yeah Nova sign me yeah both of our tits
which is a very rare in a lot of areas
after when you get into the into the
really deep into the woods you know Nova
Scotia do they don't even have post
office or anything if you want to you
just hope people know how you feeling
about them
yeah they don't allow Facebook out there
so he came and update your status so
he's like she just writes her status on
her tits
it's very Game of Thrones you can ride
through with a horse and just you know
take over a city do whatever you want
say you're looking you know just looking
for Westeros and somebody will point you
in a certain direction queen of that
ain't it I'm not mad at her dude do
where is Westeros anyway the one thing I
like about Game of Thrones is it's like
move to a different [ __ ] country like
you guys are so much in land why are you
guys fighting into this little island
you get the whole world you more also
the [ __ ] on the dragon fly somewhere
else start a new colony yeah don't tell
me anything you know that I want to ruin
it for you so bad but you know I do you
just got back from Australia so I'm
being cool dude I'm being [ __ ] cool
you know Loras is homosexual as well
yeah you've said that twice now so uh
well I'm learning as I go brother no but
I think this lady Harriet
what's-her-name felicity oh yeah she
seems like a nice lady she's dressed up
well obviously a hard-worker classy oh
sure yeah she's not a um you know she's
not the kind of lady that doesn't know
where she is she's in a hallway in this
picture looks like she's competent and
knows where she's at it looks like she
might be working in some sort of office
building yeah but like she knows
Microsoft different Microsoft programs
and probably could also be a banker or
own a small business small business
owner SBO or might be run a scheme a
Ponzi scheme of some sort a nova scotia
law that goes on out there because she
wished she could honey dick me she could
probably yeah she could probably catfish
me into stealing my money oh yeah I
could see that up there in Halifax
yeah they get creative up there brother
yeah all the time no son yeah they call
it Halle [ __ ]
too dude they don't give hella Fox yeah
they don't bro they do not do Nova
Scotia where is it that's another great
question huh puerto rico basically it's
a white Puerto Rica
Nova Scotia I'm gonna king it I don't
know how I'm like what is this one King
it dude do it rip my drip hello either
way I'm king in her and I might wrap
that one eyebrow mm-hmm oh that's that
Chris D'Elia move dude or the rock
you've gotten the planet oh yeah that's
true man that's the rock that rock I'm
talking about the pebble that's a Thalia
yeah that's that people's brow right
there bro oh that's the people's brow
dude but look if we're talking about rip
my dribblin let's do it let's see that
dress then yeah let me rip this dress oh
yeah she looks like uh like Shane
MacGowan 's Christmas ornament if you
can get a good look at her here she's
got a very she's got that tank she's got
a very kind of Christmasy sort of I
would say I've seen some woman sleeping
that someone call that a nightie where
I'm from Nova Scotia calls that a dinner
down yeah that is a dinner down what
does that dinner down dinner down dinner
down bro okay gallon starts with a G bro
oh it's just you
you got jet lag and can't speak English
to do your town down bro dinner down
same five toes dinner gown dinner gala
dinner down dinner down dinner gown oh
good do it bro yeah gown star to the G
either way she's cool man
I'm a fan of either way either way you
do an alphabet either way bro what else
we get to do it daaad bro you are in you
are an idiot
here's an ad from the king of the sting
dude your dog's health is so important
man just like you remember your family
dad your dog bro it starts my dad passed
away yeah well your dog hasn't and it's
really important you feed them good food
yeah do you know what's in your dog food
no you don't bro so you guys start using
Olly Olly puts dogs first to vet
formulated recipes that are fully
transparent ingredients to give your dog
the healthiest food possible you know
what I call dog food meat cereal da well
Dave
I'll tell you this though Ali beats out
store-bought dog food at a 10 to 1 on
the palatability scale what yeah if you
see a dog and he looks happy he's
probably on that aisle and go to my
alley calm it's a few questions about
your pup and the customize your recipe
for your dog and ship pre-portioned
meals just so you know your pups can
love it
oh if you've seen your pup and he looks
happy you know why they're meat Lucky
Charms
yeah they created yeah they they
delivered they create customized vet
formulated recipes made with all-natural
ingredients
no fake chicken no tofu no why you know
porcupine meat or whatever Doberman no
kangaroo tongue in this meal yeah nobody
they're not feeding Bichon to a Doberman
they got real legitimate meats no
preservatives sourced from us family
farm your pup starts doing the moonwalk
you can think Ollie ollie is offering
you guys enjoy pup six percent off your
first box plus a free bag of treats for
the little hound dog yep and now you got
to do is go to my alley
my oli a.com slash try /ke 80s so
support the podcast get your dog them
sack of beautiful treats and good
servings because we love the hounds oh
yeah and the hound also was in Game of
Thrones dude that's right but I'll say
it also eats this that's why it's so big
yes why he's so healthy yeah this is the
best deal they have available anywhere
go to my Ollie comm slash try /ke 80s
for 60% off did your dog plus a free bag
of treats boy get your dog to the NBA
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit you know bro I want some
dope shades but running kind of tight on
cash man really oh then you got to get
shaded up man and you shouldn't have to
choose either man between overpriced
designer sunglasses and cheap shades I
heard I heard at the water cooler
everyone's like dude make sure you get
these movement classes they're so
ridiculous everyone's gonna love you if
you get on em VMT man they usually make
watches you know a lot of people know
that but it's changed now man they have
sunglasses as well and and does it come
with free shipping free return policy
you can try on as many styles you want
right from your home home oh yeah that
babe they will basically send them to
you and you choose from there it's a los
angeles-based accessories brand MVM T
movement is that what the term yeah dog
ask me what I'm doing deal that's what
I'm doing what are you doing what are
you doing dude I'm cutting out the
middleman Oh cut out the middleman to
save money yeah man it's a los
angeles-based accessories brand movement
has hundreds of premium affordable
sunglass styles to choose from so
whether you're into more timeless shapes
like classic round Sonny's and guess
what they're all they're all polarized
everyone's like oh I need polar ice yeah
we got you man yeah don't worry about
that son anymore or something that makes
a statement like fun 90s skinny frames
movement has them all they're
constructed with durable acetate and
lightweight material I guess they start
at movement starts at sixty bucks and
nothing's over ninety five guaranteed to
find the style you're gonna love with
quality that doesn't break the bank yeah
cuz sometimes when you get that are that
real super fancy pair is too much man
now get the fancy pair at a price that
you can afford in a price that makes
sense look fly man get 15% off today
with free shipping free returns by going
to MVM t.com / k 80s
yep cym VMT keeps growing check out
their expanding collection get in there
go to MVM t.com / k 80s join the
movement joins knock knock who's there
pantheon Brendan moving on to
relationship advice first one is from
amber B
what's up girl he has a little girl
who's five who I've yet to meet
because she lives in a different state
sure he's lying and one night I wake up
to him in the middle of the night
telling me oh by the way baby momma's
decided to move to Georgia which is
where we're at um with my kid but don't
worry
everything's gonna be fine hmm there's
nothing to worry about I don't want
anything jeweler okay there's been some
red flags I really feel in my gut that
there's more to the situation than I
know
and basically I'm wanting advice for my
two favorite people and whether I should
trust my gut or Mother's him coming in
trust him and believe him and see where
it goes
appreciate it guys sorry about the dog
anyway
[ __ ] ah dog ah god damn chance you say
I'm full bro even and see where it goes
appreciate it guys sorry about the dog
anyway the hit me up Wow I love you I
want to say that back probably keep
moving forward you seem like a seem one
like someone who's been doing good stuff
and he's like a nice person seem like a
really good person yeah now you're in a
relationship but you just threw dick
shade towards my boy so how serious is a
relationship if you're trying to go
after the Rat King look you might get
cheesy you know that's all I'm saying
you might get a little wet start [ __ ]
with the rat oh you might get some wet
cheese you might get some brief yeah
here's what I'm saying is this what are
you saying Brendan I'm saying that if
it's the love of your life
hey he's not a terrible person cuz baby
mommas moving back to george and she
wants the kid to be closer with the dad
that's not a red flag but she doesn't
more to it you know she just gets these
vibes or something else
like she's never met the kid it sounded
the guys married or still putting it
back together you know a lot of guys
I'll tell you this you don't young
ladies and I hate to tell you this a lot
of guys are still married you don't want
to hear that but they are so you know
they are dude and you're right man but
with the one thing if it's their
soulmate and they're that close just
because the baby mama is moving back
because she wants the kid over they ship
but the dad doesn't mean he's a bad dude
right it doesn't mean the guy's a bad
guy that sigh if he's hiding more [ __ ]
and catch them line and if he's a
bonafide liar then yeah move on and I
can I'll slide in your DM to give you
feel phone number
well why I could just do that why are
you getting into redeems she's up Stu
has already made on her play haha on
that filter for me bro we've gone over
this I'm your filter you are yeah I
can't just let anyone get to the Rat
King you gotta go through this baby
buzz buzz gotta get to the honey forget
to the wrap mr. filter bro I'm like the
security guard for a van Halen you want
to [ __ ] the band you gonna start with me
you got to start in the van get that
honey turn that van full of honey buzz
buzz girl we'll see if we get enough for
the rat dude well you got a honey we got
cheese or like a chart shooter replay so
let me say this young lady I think you
gotta trust your instincts it sounds
like your instincts are telling you
there's some red flags here you said red
flags I need more info though before I
throw this dude down the gutter do you I
don't think you do I've been this dude
and he's a [ __ ] bag kid huh you have
more kids than I know but I've pretended
I've had kids somewhere they're coming
back to have Georgia okay you know
everybody's got that kid traveling on
the Underground Railroad or whatever
excuse you use you know so I would say
this that I think you got to take some
time for yourself do some things for
yourself if this guy's a soul mate then
it's gonna work out but I would start to
I would start to have a little bit more
time for yourself you know so don't be
at his beck and call
don't be at it nah put them up put a
little distance put them on that Fiji
Island you know I'm saying yeah so
you've been Dame for a year and there's
red flags
soul mate let's chill a little bit yeah
soul plane maybe see if you guys can get
through soul playing together without
[ __ ] yeah watch soul plan and see if you
can avoid as
cockatiel yeah cuz some movies just
supposed to watch you know supposed to
[ __ ] seven minutes into it and then just
be sitting there eleven minutes into it
with [ __ ] not knowing what's going on
you know the real trick see if you can
watch Soul plane and not talk for the
entire movie yeah it gets through that
you got to keep her yeah I think you'd
put him on that soul plane test good
luck girl next one comes from Danny
Solano he's from Chirac along with this
caboolture Rock'em you did I think Sam
was good Cleo Vaughn yeah he's good
Brendan Schwab's I gotta ask you guys
for some relationship advice swaps
lately you know I kind of feel like
she's been getting inspired by those
fake-ass IG girls with their edited eyes
pictures you know hmm you know that's
been inspiring her to hit the gym you
know she has been hitting the gym hard
you know doing squats doing weights you
know doing sit-ups and stuff and you
know she's working on that booty you
know she's trying to get it nice and
tight you know but I'm gonna be honest
with you guys you know prior to her gym
endeavors you know she had that back
hitter you feel me
she had that back clap but you know she
had that Diaz booty
yeah but down syndrome yeah man I've
been oh [ __ ] yes but he not the same
anymore
ts kept the hottest body you know it was
nice and jiggly and stuff and you know I
noticed that gluteus maximus you know
unfortunately you're starting them you
know who's moodiest maximus do to black
guys no no he's in gladiator
you know and relationships are all about
give and take
you know but don't take that out the one
thing that you know it doesn't get taken
away is that booty correct bro let me
know what you have all right we got it
bro we got it keeps throwing metaphors
for a status please Danny you like that
dude let me just say this Danny about
that booty Danny all about that is if
that anaconda don't want none unless you
got buns hun now you can do them sit-ups
but please don't use them butts
listen dude if your girl's down to get
in the gym and get them James yeah one
dancer bro you're like the teacher
you're like the chaperone at the [ __ ]
high school
no I'm dude I'm limited in this [ __ ]
government chair they got us in you know
if I can get a little more room with the
[ __ ] chair pop drop and lock it bro I
know all sorts of [ __ ] drop lock and
papi you've no regrets you bet in New
Orleans I pop I drop a lock you don't
know what you're talking about right now
you probably know school dance in your
life pop drop and locket is that when
you that's getting murder bro somebody
shoot you you fall to the ground and
then you get locked up then they lock
you up in one of those are mausoleums
dude death dude just cuz your Milan cab
the Titanic and dancing in the living
room doesn't mean you went to school
dance
yeah bro my mother played Bryan Adams
everything I do a Dewey full my McKnight
one it's like a dream come true
[Music]
three girl is plain to see these were
easy brush it was so [ __ ] yeah that
she was pedophile it's not written
account of three yeah what are you
writing songs for Sesame Street yeah
[ __ ] sweet McKnight and heard he has up
anyway um yeah it's like this Mike white
chicks love him bro white chicks chicks
love hey they do you ever seen him in
person he's played basketball I think
really that's not a race Magic Johnson
this morning at the gym no over to God
do you say what's up yeah what's up with
the eggs No
jeez what would the other dog jeez your
magic you said nothing
you didn't even say what's up you say
you're on the Rat King you need help
with the goddamn Lakers hit your boy up
I'm not saying to someone what's up with
the AIDS uh that's its but he beat it
you got a lot to learn me but he beat it
bro
just like you beat a lot of things it's
inspiring but you don't say what's up
with it if somebody beat it
this dude's advice dude listen your
girl's already down to get in the gym
and have that backside like Magic
Johnson you just gotta change let her
know what she needs to be doing them
deadlifts she need to be uploading on
them carbs I don't let it just start
eating all clean the deadlifts the squat
she can do it right pointer and Serena
Williams direction show her people who
workout with fat asses also don't hate
on them IG molluscs add them yeah that
is a good bro okay and I'll say this
dude push ready girls aren't well look
some girls that get so strong you can't
even you know the rip the chalk off it
do ya you can't even get in enter their
vaginas bro it's like trying to get into
a awesome bag that shrunk you know that
was left outside and like uh and has
like a lot of horse piss or something on
it but I'll say this man what are we
talking about what is this guy asking
his girls working out he doesn't ask
first of all be supportive if you girls
going to the gym you should get over to
the gym roll Rolly what's the guy's name
Danny Solana yes do gym Daniel Solano
I'm sorry sorry thank you for sending in
the video man we appreciate the support
well your girl comes back from the gym
just have a full rack of ribs ready to
go
yeah they're broke don't let her get on
that tilapia but be supportive man you
got look dude anything could happen bro
your girl could hip I'll get hit by
lightning and never going to the gym
again and then you got the fattest ass
in the world you know she can't move
she'd burn yeah but you got that burn
ass boy yeah you know nowhere and then
Danny's popping them burnt [ __ ] big
the many hitters yeah so look anything
could happen the future could hold
anything for you but I'd be supportive
of her man he's supportive but also is
he supportive but her losing her ass
that's like him maybe she loves his lips
I like him getting lip surgery or
[ __ ] taking down his nose maybe she
likes his big-ass nose and big ass lips
does he really
yes nose or because they're Saints not
small so let's say she loves his nose
and lips he gets rid of that she gonna
be cool with that it's a bad angle he
looks okay look I think he's he looks
fine yeah he's fine but let's say she
likes that big nose and lips and he got
rid of them you don't think she'd be
pissed he signed up for a fat ass so he
looks kind of like that hot guy in that
cartoon Arthur or whatever what's that
are are we talking about the anteater
yeah our author like the brother well
there's some anyone without glasses
Jesus I can Jesus Christ dude that's a
[ __ ] Australian cartoon bro there's
Arthur it's what I'm talking about you
know the other guy would think Arthur
shoot how dare you he's dead yeah there
he's right beyond the left
Oh Tim right there he does kind of look
like him it looks like that guy he does
look like him Wow
dude just hop just feed your girl let
her work out but make sure gang how many
Awards do I get because I'm a champion
of something to hit the [ __ ] touch me
they look identical Jesus Christ first
of all if you look like a drawing
brother you cannot criticize your woman
okay get out there and be supportive
slap that ass draw a bigger ass on to
her small ass get her fake ass get some
fake ass and hook it onto the side of
her before sex dude you know I'm saying
there's always brazilian butt-lift bro
yeah ties some t-shirts are under the
legs and pretend it's ass right ass on
each one of them think outside of the
[ __ ] bud
what else Jin you like fat asses I like
I'm softer than more muscly you like
soft asses they have to be softer to
lead it's not a [ __ ] a bay shrimp
broth can avoid softer than I don't like
this hard steaming carrot yeah Chen I
don't like a rock-hard ass I don't like
an aspirin flike a girl falls out of a
window it makes like a pink sandwich
exactly
that's crazy break my dick on a [ __ ]
iceberg ass yeah like I'm soft what else
this is flat my aunt first one is aunt
Gaby yeah damn who's aunt is this is
submitted by Camila Camila Camila let's
read this a seat jiminee can you yeah I
got some stuff on it so this is
submitted by Camila she's 29 years old
born in Denmark half Cuban half Chilean
Wow professional hip-hop dancer pop drop
and lock it is right now we're talking
pop drop pocket pop pop pop baby yeah
[ __ ]
oh snap crackle puss bro this girl is a
very handsome young lady aunt Gabe and
my Sugar Smacks oh she definitely she
would make me definitely buy a [ __ ]
eight ball you know I need to look I
drink a whole 12-pack of fosters and
talked about dancing all right
I'd watch her shed a layer of skin bro
this this girl's fine as hell Crocodile
Dundee right now be damned oh definitely
doing it for us isn't she
dude she is just half Cuban half Chilean
what else an angel
broad wash her body just as she'd go on
a date with another man bro I'm that
kind of guy suck on her feet before she
left the crib Oh bro I'd suck on her
feet just as she could town trying
really tight shoes because if he would
still be damned I'm listening to
Nickelback every day for just look tell
her how bad they suck while she go smoke
sup with other dudes dude I'd lay on her
chest with my back to her breasts and
pretend that we're listening to nipple
back and make a corny joke and see if
she likes it she likes it god damn risk
it all for her dude oh I'll jump in the
Pacific Ocean right now just full of
[ __ ] blood
for caught Chum in the water yeah [ __ ]
yeah dude I can't believe you can
[ __ ] read here's what I'm saying is
dude I would definitely pull it if I saw
her trying to hitchhike dude I'd pull
over on the side of the road and lock
her in my basement for a month okay Ted
Bundy oh it's a nice basement dude
especially a man cave okay but the locks
are on the outside you know feeder
feeder yeah bro I'm gonna open up an
Arby's in the hair dude I'm gonna do
everything I can fart oh yeah we got the
beat do I buy our full rack of ribs
every day of my life if you wanted I
will do that for you
this is uncle Trey he's 29 years old
that's Conor McGregor it looks just like
worst of all he does look very similar
that's him doubling quints
what's his he's a former Army Ranger and
Special Forces soldier six feet tall
over 200 pounds and he puts Bryan Callen
stream men submitted by Alomar in North
Carolina and he's blind or not I don't
know I don't think so he's just hiding
the dead behind his eyes cuz killed so
many [ __ ] people
Wow Special Forces hey you're welcome
for his free for your freedom because of
that man I appreciate it yeah you're
welcome dude you like being the Rat King
and [ __ ] flying to Australia playing
grab-ass with the koalas touching the
genitals
tell him say thank you thank you sir I
want to thank you for your service I
want to thank everybody for their
service
shut up to this [ __ ] [ __ ] killer
dude this Men's Wearhouse [ __ ]
tailored suit killers oh this guy seems
like the kind of guy that would hide
inside of a strip or a cake real quietly
with a stripper bachelor party and then
pop out and kill every guy misses and
that kind of guy yeah see you still get
a lap dance after yeah well SEAL team 69
God dude definitely this guy he's
definitely he's uh yeah he's definitely
like kind of chips like California how
his like chips and Dale he's like kind
of a guy who could be a stripper but
also be a highway patrolman he's a
baller
oh he's a baller there's one arm does he
has one army as to looks like
- but you can't see it yeah I'd like to
oh yes yeah I'd like to see those great
white eyes that he has the shark guy
what if he has no eyes bro when he takes
his sunglasses off but he still moves
fluidly about the room well you know I
want to be surprised bro
yeah he looks like the kind of dude that
would [ __ ] Tonya Harding bro and not
even go to sleep and still go to work
the next day at the bank it looks like
you'd [ __ ] Tanya hard and hurt her knee
yeah well I can't even agree to make any
[ __ ] sense but yeah move it on that's
her thing yeah she heard Nancy Kerrigan
who's now a schoolteacher did you hear
that no was she teaching how to be a
crybaby
they did say she's real whiny that's
what always her friend Amun dated her
actually really yep said she's [ __ ]
whining all the time I need money God is
17 years ago yeah give it up yeah yeah
people have lost their limbs and you're
out here skating first of all if you
skate enough dude
somebody's gonna [ __ ] hit you with
something bro yeah skating gets on
peoples nerves yeah stand you dancing on
ice get on my face and then be regular
dance yeah your neighbours a skater dude
get the F bro what else we got chin
alright there's somebody that's afraid
to be a stripper I feel like yeah
there's gonna be fancy strippers yeah
last movie last for my aunt is aunt
Darlene this show focus yeah yeah she
looks like somebody that bets on Conor
McGregor you want to know some stats on
her yeah she's identical twins with the
submitters mom her name is Darla the mom
okay single mother of four and cook and
og and this was submitted by Christian
she looks like she's [ __ ] selling her
mixtape on the streets of New Orleans
yeah she definitely seems like she
seemed like an everyday type of lady
she's down obviously she's chucking the
deuce right there or that's a mom gang
sign that's a mom club that's a gang out
there yeah it's a single mom gang sign
she's got four children she said so she
so you know she's a beast
yes she's obviously a freak in the
sheets see if she's got four kids if
somebody worked for little weasels out
of her womb and but uh but she
definitely look I love a redhead
you know shoutout to all the single moms
out there I you know she's obviously
holding it down for children
unbelievable yeah you only have two tits
so how do you even feed him if to feed
to and watch to destruct
you know do hopscotch or something I
mean I can imagine
it's a Spartan life really is man 2 out
of the 4 inch eopsi picked but it's kind
of confusing because she's throwing gang
signs with the left hand then the right
hands holding black power yes she does
have that black panel looks like she has
a gram over there in her hand she's got
a cigarette amah brought indoors looks a
little staged but she does have that
proper 12 and she's got a about 43
dollars on the ground 143 she's betting
on something yeah there's a lot going on
here man yeah yeah look I would uh I'd
buy her a drink at a casino yeah I take
her on a date I take her somewhere nice
I'd take her to a nice maybe Polish meal
somewhere she looks like she'd like a
date with you at the outback or
something you know yeah I take her
somewhere [ __ ] nice boy maybe TGI
Fridays I don't like that place that
much I would take her out back then on a
Friday to uh on a Friday night
get there early to kind of beat the rush
but yeah I mean sure we have to eat at
4:50 p.m. you need reservations if you
can go on a Friday night let's be real
so I'm saying we get there 4:50 p.m. and
just have a couple of drinks for maybe
take a bad name movie hmm they've taken
a nice matinee as well
here are some Raisinets I don't like
going into movies when it's bright when
you go in and it's dark when you coming
out just scares me worse me too yeah God
it's the worst feel like you wasted your
day
well you just feel like somebody took
advantage of your summer they cheated
you out of like time when you were in
there honest don't like it I don't like
that so you missed out on the world when
that happen take time warps yeah me
neither
shout out to this lady but thank you
very much yeah
last segment of the day debate club
first one is from William I think that's
his name because there's no name what's
Ryan Willie Brendan Bo debate club which
one's worse wedgies or swirlies Gang
Gang buzz buzz damn I was Ryan Willie
dude oh do we have the video from Ryan
Willie where that's my boy yeah dude he
won the X Games this past weekend in
Shanghai but when he did a gang gang
buzz buzz flesh - yeah dude that that
famous picture you on a scooter on a
lime or something but not like that dude
I ain't jumping hills not doing any
tricks huh no I'm not like him yeah I'm
too big for that
what was his uh earlier wedgie yeah bro
wedgie not a big deal having me all the
time as a kid just pick it out and keep
moving with your day swirly your whole
day's [ __ ] ruined
you smell like dick for the rest of the
day here's all wet everyone knows you
were at swirly Dan bullied come on this
is so easy they used to give red-bellied
Abbas where they would like the dumbest
kids at school or the older kids really
and I mean real old or so like 30 years
old so like and this is 8th grade so
they would come and hold you down and
then other kids would drive in who had
nothing to do who weren't working and
they would drink an event oh they would
jump the fence and they would all just
hit your stomach until it was so red so
red bell oh yeah dude it was miserable
and the girl you had a crush on was
always standing right there watching and
I couldn't do anything to [ __ ] you're
trying to look tough oh dude so bro
there was nothing worse dude did you
have friends when it was your birthday I
guess there's a loose term friends who
would punch you as how many times old
you were but really punchy like give you
the worst charley horse no I'll do my
friends I just have black and blue marks
I stay I hate my birthday Jesus you
never step that it sounds like it a
stepdad you're right that's my stuff dad
it could have been line up every year
but I say I don't like swirlies only
somebody putting their finger in my ear
with the with our saliva on it or see oh
that's a wet willy what country are you
from
really they take your [ __ ] here and
dump you into the water the toilet water
so yeah turds
no they don't yeah it's a swirly bro
you're thinking of us what is it chin I
didn't know that was really yeah come on
yeah you listen to our they have
plumbing worries from get out of here
don't eat a whole oh my god bro you're
going to hell why is that going to help
get me out of this conference get me out
of this hold on
what's everyone think is swirly is did
anyone know what this really was cat
yeah I'm not a [ __ ] Lillee you
[ __ ] foreigners bro well 72% of the
audience says swirly is worse you know
what they say man foreigners can't be
choosers bro here's what I'm saying is
this bro I don't know what a swirly is
[Music]
school I think it has some jetlag hit me
mash got time let me give you a swirly
like it's a middle of a night now let me
give you a swirly know if like it's the
middle of the night I feel like I'm
getting interrogated very poorly by five
detectives that's fair yeah I feel like
it get to the next one chin Nick had all
this prepare like we're trying to act
like we're trying to solve a murder
myself all right so the next one is
submitted by Dylan Johnson from
Minnesota its jock jams vs. that's what
I that's what I call music Michael
buffer let's get ready to rumble that's
not a song oh are you ready for this not
a real song hurry these are jock jam pop
race y'all Jam oh you know this one pump
up pump up the volume pump up pump up
YMCA you get the [ __ ] out of my face
pump pump the jam pop it up why your
feet are stompin I don't always got him
on there
what is this his [ __ ] all sucks what's
the next see the other one this is what
I now that's what I call music
red red wine you know close to me dude I
can't I can't [ __ ] get jiggy with
this [ __ ]
what is this is all [ __ ] man this is all
[ __ ] that's the first one
jock jam jock jams jock jams for the
wind baby
what I don't think so I'd rather jock
itch brother than jock jams I'd rather
scratch my dick once and I don't have to
hear any of that music I like John right
get us out of here chin so jock jams it
was my 51% it was a close call what's up
fans who know what the [ __ ] going on
in the world probably six people boy
let's get this video cooler feel Frank
is one over here needs a nap last one
dudes it's Adrian Valdivia a do brand
man got that big club for you little bro
or big bro who's cooler don't [ __ ]
touch any more info before I do no I
don't think he knows play one more time
so you see these guys man I like their
vibe man I do Brendan got a dick big
club for you little bro or big bro who's
cooler just don't [ __ ] touch me don't
[ __ ] touch khabib first of all I
don't know if anybody noticed that or
not do you have brothers yeah I got a
brother man my brother's name is F and
he looks he looks a little bit like that
guy man no I don't think your brothers
in a band
other than ZZ Top cover band he could
have been in a band after I asked him I
don't know if he doesn't tell me
everything he older younger he's two
years older than me would he beat you up
when you're younger yeah oh we would
[ __ ] hit each other with chairs and
stools yeah W so bored thank God mom had
a sword that was very not sharp yeah
don't so easiest thing yes I hear you
man my brother's evil as well definitely
if you're a little brother you kind of
learned the ropes of life that it ain't
easy yes definitely the little brother
for the window you learn how to get hit
by a sword that's for sure so I'm gonna
say you got to be cooler man if you're
the one sitting in the video that's what
i'ma say that you're obviously a king in
the stinger you know and you're part of
the Gang Gang buzz-buzz you know tribe
so I think that you're cooler man I
don't know I just hit a brick wall
and I just get some [ __ ] heroin in
your veins oh I wish I could do it on my
[ __ ] after zacapa gram because I
gotta tighten up or loosen up one of the
other tight no bro you would yeah
tighten up yeah go get some steroids
dude oh I used to do steroids when I was
young there's no contest I know you had
a bunch of energy just a con bro breast
feed I could just go ahead all Avoyelles
on my test row make that deca [ __ ]
sandwich I broke my I was like the last
the last stop on a Subway sandwich line
bro just [ __ ] who wants mayonnaise
yeah was that [ __ ] winner guard
whatever do you pick
older brother younger younger I'm the
younger brother he's younger brothers
yeah younger brother nation bro you're
younger - right ma'am dude - any scars
yes you did
Wow he was crazier than me but the
audience says 63% older brothers they
sure weren't driving on actual roads bro
that's one of the benefits of it ybn bro
younger brother nations son held a
little runts in the house want to thank
chin for for stopping in last minute and
taking over the water today
yeah shut up the chin hopefully Derek's
alright on the road hopefully Nick's
okay yeah Jonnie dates coming up brother
yeah man I do the I think everything's
sold out right now except for oslo and
stockholm which are those are in some
other country somewhere I know where
they are
keep down
[Music]
there's no way thank you very much dude
thank you
Sweden and Norway yeah I'm obviously
gonna kill myself if you look at that
toward a Calgary Yuk Yuk's june 20th
through the 22nd and then Brad come on
down the Bray improv that's June 27th
through 29th kids tickets now t5k calm
bro I'm glad you're back brother
oh dude I'm laughing at you yeah glad
you're black oh I'm happy to be back
here where the alphabet is yeah you know
it for debate yeah it's up for debate
without the bets good to see you bro
yeah brother don't [ __ ] touch me not
see you guys next thank you guys
[Music]